let's talk about decluttering our mobile
phones home screen dude I'd finally
found a good solution to this actually
based off one of your recommendations
you were talking about how the Kindle
app is you have that out on your main
screen and what what that made me ask
myself is when I go to my phone what do
I wish I went to every single time a
great question
yeah so the it's the Kindle and it's the
audio we're gonna write this down by the
way it's the Kindle app and the audible
app which by the way all the minimalist
books can be found on audible.com
alright so so that's what I did man I
took and then you know the four so I got
iPhone and the four little folders on
the bottom right so they were not
folders they are the main apps well what
I did is I moved every single I created
four folders and moved to the bottom
I've got I've got utilities
I've got travel I have entertainment and
I have social now social media but
social and social is like Skype what is
the Apple service communication is
really urgent
yeah really yeah it's time FaceTime yeah
text messages things like that there's
only one you can't swipe on that folder
like there's only one page right there
the other ones have a few different
pages to swipe on but if I'm looking for
an app and I can't find it
like there's there's something wrong
with that like me having that IP that
I'm not using it enough and I do that
sometimes like in the travel folder for
example I'll download I don't know Aer
Lingus app because I'm in Europe and I'm
flying Aer Lingus well there's not a
Lingus in the United States so yeah I've
got like download that when I went when
I'm on vacation and then I'll delete it
when I when I come back to the States
but it's crazy though like you know
Mariah had my phone and she's like oh
you know can I you know she's asking to
look at my phone to get to something
whether it's you know our plane tickets
or whether I'm asking her to write
something down in the notebook I know
exactly where everything is in that
phone yeah like I could say oh that is
oh that's a utility you need to go to
the utility folders third page in the
center like I know exactly where it's at
so
for me like that is what has worked best
and I love it man because with my phone
when I you know if I get a notification
the only thing I see is like that
actually I mean oh yeah I guess I do get
the little window notification but all I
see are those two apps Kindle inaudible
and that's it and it feels so good and
when after I wish I would have went to
that I I did something similar with with
the Kindle app where when I got
Instagram off my phone because that was
like the thing I would find myself just
unconsciously scrolling to like I was
like a habit like I knew where it was
well I replaced where it was with the
Kindle app and then soon I found myself
I unconsciously reading a book all of a
sudden and that's so much better I also
use a great app called instapaper
I don't know if you ever used that
anytime that I and I pay for it so I
have make sure I've like an ad-free
version
I always pay for things whenever I can
get the ad-free version whether it's
YouTube patreon but what I'll do with
this the paper is like say someone sends
me in New York Times article you're like
hey just you really need to read this
thing about you know the top ten podcast
or whatever it is or here's a really
great article about David Foster Wallace
I will just hit on my web browser I hit
instapaper and it puts it on my instant
paper on my phone so that when I have a
free moment I instead of trying to
search social media or something I can
just read the articles that I've been
meaning to catch up on oh my god did I
used to have I don't do this anymore
because I've just made the rule that if
I don't read it right away I'm just
probably not gonna read it it's a very
good rule to I I so I in my instant
paper I go in once a week and delete
anything I haven't read but there are
some things where like a week later I'm
like oh I got a I will look up someone's
text or email and that's how I know I
really want to I really want to read it
but I love this into the paper idea but
dude I can't tell you how many times I
just have like 20 tabs open anything
like that would stress me out so then I
would just like create a new window to
like do whatever work I wanted to do and
then forget about this 20 Duff and they
have like another 10 tabs open it's like
its own clutter oh my god dude or up you
remember the dude who was at our event
and he was like I need some advice on
all these bookmarks I have he's like I
got booked right I got over like 500
bookmarks remember this on things that
I'll read one
day and you know how do you suggest that
get through reading these and I'm like
honestly man get rid of them all like
lead him on he deleted him right there
and he did and he told me how relieved
he felt and it's it's crazy though I did
ask him like hey look if he wants your
phone right now and imagine that somehow
they accidentally got deleted like how
would you feel
remember we need to leave my whole memo
notepad yeah not on purpose no wasn't on
purpose it was on accident trying to
trying to get my new phone working I
mean there were a couple small like
there are some jokes on there I wish I
would add and you ever coming to me for
tech support that's a couple essays but
ultimately though it wasn't it wasn't as
bad as what I anticipated in the same
way I lost 200 essays recently the oh my
god I don't like their fragments of
different essays because I went to him
to like because I've been writing this
book yeah and I'm like I'll just go to
my essay fragment see if I got some good
ideas here and they were gone there was
two of them left I don't know what
happened to him oh my goodness it's
literally just 200 essay revenge
I screwed both of us so yeah I'll say
two things to finish out the the home
screen
I have no icons like you on my home
screen and I do have those folders at
the bottom and I remove anything that is
distracting I will constantly ask myself
what am I being distracted by now
thankfully you can also track your your
productivity time and at the time you're
spending on different apps if you're
spending too much time then you can
remove that app for a period of time and
then bring it back in if you really feel
like it's gonna add value here are some
apps I do get immense value from brain
FM is one yeah if I am if I'm really
trying to work and concentrate they have
a I think it's seven bucks a month so
it's not cheap but I use it all the time
if I'm trying to write a book like they
have a concentration feature so I just
have my earbuds in and it's like
concentration music if I want to take a
nap they have nap music if I want to
just relax they have relaxed music if I
want to sleep they have deep sleep music
and so it's it's really helpful I use it
all the time I use a podcast app called
overcast although I'm finding the
podcast for me are too addictive
I'm getting immense value from a handful
of them and so what I'm going to do it
not only am I going to do this again I
did it last year it's time to do it
again I'm gonna unsubscribe from all the
podcasts that I subscribe to I'm gonna
Reese absque Ribe to only the ones I
miss but I'm also gonna set up some
parameters about when I can listen to
podcasts and it's gonna be when I'm
exercising when I'm walking to work not
when I'm just walking because I walk a
lot and that's when I do a lot of my
best thinking for writing and so I don't
want to just be listening to podcasts
all the time but if I'm walking directly
to work instead of driving to work I
give myself permission or if I'm driving
somewhere I'll give myself permission to
listen to podcasts but I rarely drive
anymore so there will be certain times I
can listen to podcasts other times I'm
just going to have to sit alone with my
own thoughts as crazy as that might be
hmm other apps that I get value from
I've already talked about the Kindle app
we talked about audible we talked about
Instapaper those are the big ones for me
but the other one is FaceTime you know
I'm not always with backs or Ella and so
I get immense value from being able to
interact with them on on FaceTime if you
want a really good wallpaper for your
phone a nice reminder once you've gotten
all the apps off the homescreen head on
over to the minimalists comm slash love
people we have a love people use things
wallpaper over there that you can
download for free
you